Hey how's it gone so Cortez how you
doing man pretty good this is the mkbhd
and Dennis Woodside Google+ hangout on
air so first time I've done one of these
in a long time but I'm excited for this
one so first of all if you want to
introduce yourself I'm assuming you
don't really need a huge introduction
for the people who are watching this but
in three sentences who are you then so
what's that ah so I'm Dennis I'm the CEO
Motorola I'm a dad I got two kids 12
year-old actually 13 year old now in the
eleven year old who are who are actually
fans Marquez of your reviews and our our
our aspiring tech reviewers themselves
they critique everything that we do so
nice ah but it's great too great to be
on air with you right so yeah that's
good to have so basically we have the
event we've had the event page up for
they think two days or so and there's a
lot of questions that people have about
Motorola and everything that you guys
are doing and it's a good time of year
to talk about stuff like this so I'm
just going to go straight to like the
most popular stuff which is the Moto X
because everyone talking about it
everyone wants to know about it
um so the the whole cyber monday huge
spike in demand with what kind of can
you describe like breakdown what
happened um basically with that whole
thing yeah so you know we were we were
overwhelmed by the response to the offer
the $150 offf offer and and as I said
when in sort of the note that I sent out
earlier in the week we we were we were
under prepared for the kind of demand
that we saw for for that that offer on
Monday and we shouldn't have been but we
were now the good news is that we
rallied and were able to change the
system so that we could issue coupons
for folks to come back and and come into
the Moto maker site and make their
devices and even then the demand was
overwhelming we sold literally tens of
thousands of thousands of coupons in
formats and which was our allotment of
you know the devices that we could
actually build for the for the promotion
so I
thinking we learned a lot you know the
the there's clearly demand for devices
that are not tied to a contract at
prices that are reasonable and I think
you know we're going to listen hard to
that to what that the consumer told us
on Monday and on Wednesday you know
we're going to do it again on Monday of
next week so 9:00 a.m. Pacific noon
Eastern will have the same offer we have
you know again we can't we can't put
massive quantities into that kind of an
offer but but I think we're going to
explore this notion of different pricing
or price points and trying to do a
little bit more for consumers that want
those devices that aren't tied to plans
and and I think that that's a big
opportunity for us yeah yeah because I
was I I did a video just on the Moto X
for that off-contract three and fifty
dollar price versus a nexus 5 two very
opulent and it's funny because in the
United States not a lot of people
actually buy phones off contract until
obviously this gigantic spike so I was I
was interested to see how many I sold so
that's pretty impressive tens of
thousands of people decided that that
was a good idea um yeah I may be more
right we don't really know however how
significant the demand was I think
you're also seeing it with the carriers
are realizing this too so 18 t just this
week announced that they have a new
share plan which allows you to bring
your own phone and then your bill is $15
less a month so I think you know as the
market broadens I think about my kids
you know for for students students don't
necessarily can necessarily afford a
data plan an annual plan and a lot of
students don't have the credit scores to
get an annual data plan right so they're
going prepaid and they're bringing their
own device and they're going
month-to-month and that's it that's a
real opportunity and we also saw with
republic Wireless right so we partnered
with republic Wireless to bring X to
them they're doing incredibly well with
with with a combination of X and their
service which again allows for much more
flexible data
pricing month-to-month you can actually
change your plan mid month from a five
dollar plan to a forty dollar plan if
you need 4G you know so I think you're
going to see a lot more creative plans
and you're going to and we're going to
try to provide the devices that help
those plans come to fruition yeah
definitely I think pricing is extremely
important when it comes to that kind of
stuff just because of the type of people
that would want to buy an off contract
phone or just any phone it happens to be
a good deal um but continue along
continually continuing along motox so a
lot of people were asking about the wood
backs because the whole customization
thing is really important for the Moto X
and a lot of people are interested when
are people going to be able to get wood
backs from moto maker yeah so you know
we're working hard to get to get wood
into the mix the the issue is is simply
getting making the product
manufacturable and making sure we're
we're using materials that are
sustainable and so forth so I wanted to
say coming soon and my team isn't
letting me say anything more than that
but believe me it's soon yes I was
really surprised by actually how many
people were interested in a wood back
device I was I have a moto X in this
sort of black and yellow combination and
I like that but I was surprised but how
many people care about like having that
wood back on their fire and are willing
to wait for it so that's pretty
interesting yeah you know I think what's
cool about moto maker is it's really
just the start we can do lots of things
with different materials over time which
we're working on for for next year and
and even even into the early part of
January February so I think you'll see
more choices in moto maker as we as we
bring some of these materials and now
each time we do a new material you have
to test all the radio frequencies and
make sure the phone actually still works
so it's actually a lot of work to add
new material into the mix yeah
definitely and there's already a ton of
options already but speaking of options
a lot of people are also curious about
availability of the phones in general
because we mentioned in the United
States you know that particular market
has a sort of a changing way of how they
buy phones
contractors on contract the different
carriers and stuff like that then
there's the whole international market
and a ton of people have been asking me
when can I buy a motox in Europe or in
South America or in Asia and whole lot
of different countries yeah so so motox
is available now all throughout latin
america and in fact in in some places
like Chile and Brazil it's among the top
selling smartphones right now so so the
market is is clearly there we're working
to bring moto maker into Latin America
so you have the customization options as
well there's a much more limited set of
custom choices that we have made
available mostly in Brazil and then
outside of the Latin America we're
exploring a bunch of places Europe is
obviously a key area for us so I would
just say stay tuned we're going to get
there certainly for for some time in the
next year okay yeah that's good a lot of
people work like that's probably the
number one question I've gotten like in
my inbox is I live in this country why
not I get it well we wanted to but we
wanted to make sure we were successful
in our home market in the US and in
Latin America or were also also story
been strong before we went out outside
with with Moto X right and so it's also
it's the Moto maker I guess every Moto X
is being manufactured in are assembled
in the United States does that is that
have an effect in the way you guys are
scheduling like where you ship to next
well they're there they're assembled
really around the world so for the Moto
X is that we we shipped to Brazil we
make them in Brazil we have a facility
there we make them in in Argentina as
well for for per other markets so so
yeah one of the things that's challenge
though with Moto maker is you need to be
close to the consumer so we have to we
really had to reengineer our entire
supply chain to be able to bring moto
maker to consumers and that'll be the
same for any other country where we
bring moto maker in we're going to have
to really think through the supply chain
issues which are challenging right okay
I'm going to move to the next big
question or big topic I'm just going to
say it my next video is a review of the
Moto G cool great that's the first time
I've said that bike
my next video is about so next video is
about tomato G spoiler alert I really
like it and obviously for the price it's
a great option for a ton of people
especially because it's so cheap
off-contract to get exact and
availability is also another thing
because this I believe is is going to be
available in more countries like right
off the bat is that right is yeah so you
know moto G is is part of our vision too
we think of the product that we're
selling is not just a device it's really
the mobile Internet and if you think
about the world today there's a billion
people with smartphones but there's five
billion people without smartphones and
four billion of those five billion are
using feature phones today so a
challenge for that we've given ourselves
is how do we help bring those four
billion people into the mobile web
because once you're on the mobile web
your life improves right you're more
efficient you can you can get around
easier because you understand navigation
and traffic and all that stuff that you
get on any smart phone today you can
communicate better with your friends you
can record your world with with with the
camera so we just think it's a good
thing and and so moto G is really the
first product that's headed in that
direction which is how do we how do we
create a phone that's as good as iPhone
5 objectively as good as iPhone 5 for
third the cost that was the challenge to
the team and really the technology has
gotten there the the screen technology
and the cost of the screen technology
has gotten to the point where you can
build that and and so that's what we did
with Moto G it's available now in the
major Western European countries of UK
France Spain and all throughout Latin
America primarily Brazil in Mexico it's
available online in the US and then in
q1 it'll be available
horizon a whole bunch of other places so
pretty much everywhere you would want to
buy a phone ah we're doing pretty well
so if you go to amazon co uk or Amazon
site in France or Spain or Germany or
even Amazon in the US now it's it's
typically the number one selling
smartphone and what I like to do is read
the reviews on
because you know those are consumers who
bought the phone and and the reviews
have been really good everybody
understands that this is like an amazing
phone for for a totally exceptional
price and and people are excited about
it
yeah and I was fast that it's already on
top of those charts which is really
impressive yeah check it out check it
out yeah so so having I've owned it for
a little bit now uh but I also have a
moto X and that just got KitKat so
Android 4.4 um so my natural question is
when is moto G going to see Android 4.4
so so we'll ship in the US will ship in
beginning in January on KitKat and then
four markets outside the US we're going
to get it up to KitKat as quickly as we
can probably sometime in January okay
that's awesome
um so next big next big topic I guess is
sort of a more ambiguous one people are
just generally curious about a project
ara so yeah I also did a video on
product RI just because that hold
phonebloks concept where that sort of
video initially went viral and everyone
was talking about it and I was surprised
by how many people were talking about it
because I didn't realize that so many
people were interested in the idea um so
just if you could tell me
generally what are you guys working on
with project ara what does what does
that look like for you guys yeah well so
the idea behind our is what if you could
change the camera on your phone to have
maybe a more expensive camera but one
that has super zoom properties or what
if someone invents a sensor that you can
pour it onto your phone that measures my
health and some interesting and new way
right look right today your phone can't
once you buy it it really can't change
that much the software can change but
the hardware can't change right and we
wanted to think about how do we how do
we modularize the phone because
different parts of the phone are
developing at different speeds right
imaging technology is developing at a
different speed than the core processing
technology and and consumers are going
to have different times in their lives
when they might want to do different
things with the phone if I'm going on a
on a trip I might want a different
camera so that's the whole idea behind
our
is how do we modularize the phone to
enable innovation in different ways and
enable people to innovate in ways that
are hard to do now because everything is
in one one phone right so so we've
opened up our site basically to to
solicit participants in project ara and
then we give the missions and the
missions are things like you know
basically idea-driven come up with an
idea for a new sensor that we could
incorporate into into a project ara
phone right so that's the kind of thing
that we're working on we're going to see
where it goes you know will we have a
product in the next 12 months it's hard
to say but we're pretty excited about
about what we're doing and if you if
people are interested who are watching
the site just look for D Scout comm a
forward slash ara and you'll and you're
sorry back sorry and you'll see the
you'll see the the way to register yeah
yeah I actually register for that pretty
recently so technically speaking like a
lot of people talking about are like you
know really confuse like how is anything
like this possible I think I read the
the sort of tagline for the the one
sentence idea was sort of making the
hardware as modular as Android was able
to make the socket which is now really
that's a pretty bold statement yeah um
and I think of other like more dedicated
technologies like if I'm really into
cameras and I buy a DSLR
I have interchangeable lenses and that's
alright modularity in itself so it's
definitely interesting to see a phone
with as compacted packages we're used to
seeing phones as tightly knit is that
becoming at least the idea becoming
feasible that it's modular I was gonna
ask how how close to the phone blocks
video there the phone blocks concept is
ara you know the the there are prototype
and it is it is pretty close I mean it's
it's the idea is that you have a
skeleton that holds together a set of
components and the components literally
slide in and out and and if we had the
interfaces and the protocols that
enabled the you know the speaker to
speak directly to
to the CPU then this would all be
possible and you can change your speaker
out but but the industry really hasn't
yet set standards for those interfaces
so that so every phonus has a somewhat
proprietary set of interfaces and a lot
of what the engineers at Motorola do are
designed those interfaces and that's how
you build a phone today but but what's
cool about foam blocks and just the
concept is you know if you have the
skeleton and you define those interfaces
it does become possible to start
plugging and playing and that's what we
want to enable and then also you're
going to have people around the world
inventing stuff and we're not going to
know what that is that right no
individual is going to invent the
perfect imager or the perfect speaker
but collectively it's it's very possible
someone will come up with something
really cool yes that's another thing
that's sort of once you have the ability
to have like modular parts and like you
said really cool you can actually slide
in and slide out a certain part like
figuring out who makes the parts and
where do you get the parts and maybe uh
you know third-party manufacturers or
companies or just entrepreneurs will
come up with cool stuff is there any
idea of like hardware partners or anyone
you'd want to work with specifically
like it would be really nice if you get
XYZ to make parts for something like oh
you know there's already a bunch of
companies that are involved that have
that have thought of that they wanted to
get into this space but it's hard now so
if you're let's say you are really good
at making speakers and very small form
factors and there are companies who
specialize in that to get your product
into into a phone you have a limited
number of companies that you can work
with you can work with us you can work
with Samsung and so forth ah but if you
didn't have to have that limited
companies you can just put it out into
the market just like you can an
application wow that's pretty cool maybe
maybe there are 10,000 people out there
who really want what you've produced and
all you need is that kind of open
approach and a different approach to
hardware that's what we're really trying
to do and if we can stick started
that innovation in hardware that would
be we think that's going to result in in
some really interesting devices down the
road and definitely
um and so another one more thought on
ARRA I'm taking a class called computers
in society this semester where we like
really looked into this idea of like you
have a ship that sails the seven seas or
whatever and as it gets old you start to
replace the parts so you replace I don't
know the hull to replace the the deck
you slowly replace parts right by the
end of maybe five years later that ship
is still sailing and you've replaced all
the parts because it's still the same
ship and that's the sort of question we
looked into so with Aurra you kind of
have that skeleton ah I guess a question
is like how long would that skeleton
last and if you replaced all the parts
the sort of compatibility becomes an
issue sort of the same obviously it's
going to be interesting so yeah and then
you could imagine releases every year of
it just like an orator has a new release
every year there could be new releases
each year that allow even more
functionality to be changed and modified
we're gonna have to see where it goes
right okay cool um so back to just a
whole Motorola thing as you guys as
Google and Motorola work together I have
no idea how closely are far apart
they're working so what are like Google
and Motorola working on together because
Moto X was a pretty awesome
collaboration in the first place well no
moto X was all Motorola I mean so
Motorola is we're owned by Google so we
have financial support from Google but
we operate completely independently and
and and Google has been pretty clear
that it wants to preserve that
independence because Android is an open
source platform and and it's important
for any partner who wants to build a
product based on Android to be treated
the same way
so you know Motorola has a long history
of innovating and and you really saw
that with Moto X I think what what
Google ownership has brought to my role
is the ability to think a little bit
longer term because we have we have a
you know a patient investor that thinks
about opportunities over long periods of
time and understands that all computing
is going mobile it's a really massive
opportunity and then over time everybody
ought to have a smartphone so we just
sort of have Motorola taken
that that guidance and that freedom to
think big and that resulted in motox
emoji and and then of course there's a
bunch of other things that are in the
pipeline and and that's that's how it's
been working okay
so has anything about the way Motorola
operates changed since Google's backing
of our ownership oh yeah tons of things
I mean I you know the company had
launched 45 smartphones the year before
we acquired it in our product portfolio
now in the last 12 months we've launched
seven so we want to do fewer things and
we want to do them better we had changed
the software strategy pretty pretty
dramatically to focus on providing
updates and upgrades as quickly as we
could we thought that was something that
the market this wasn't doing and that
consumers want the latest version of
Android as close to its public release
as possible so weary architected our
entire code base in order to do that and
you saw it with with with Moto X which
upgraded 20 days after the public code
drop on on Verizon which is which is a
very advanced network and requires very
high certifications and stability in
order to in order to be able to to
upgrade so so we've changed quite a bit
about the approach of the company the
philosophy Motorola hadn't had a product
that was marketed globally and that
could compete with iPhone and the galaxy
line and we're building that brand with
Moto X and the Moto brand we think
that's really important we're trying to
engage a lot more directly with
consumers you know I respond to emails
all the time and you know go on all the
blogs and look at the comments and then
send my team notes why are we doing this
you know someone's complaining me about
it and actually I think it makes for a
much more responsive company and that's
really important because if your
consumers moving so fast that we have to
be we have to listen so so we've
actually changed quite a bit about how
the company operates but but that
doesn't mean that Google is is actually
you know running running Motorola
employment on a day to day basis we're
still pretty independent okay yeah so
that's that's a new direction like
having it's something I've seen a lot
more recently
our companies try to focus on less
devices and better maintain them so
obviously yeah exactly that KitKat on
the the Moto X on Verizon blew my mind
boo a lot of people's minds because I
was probably the best example of of
getting a product updated as quickly as
possible on a network like that so
that's that was really impressive to me
so props for that um so yeah okay that's
that's about all that say that Becca's
like having having those quick updates
and having a size really proper doing
that you know okay we can't leave we
can't leave consumers behind and it's
it's just to make when when when
something new is out there consumer
wants as fast as possible it's pretty
simple but but it actually required us
to change a lot in order to deliver that
cool
okay um my next topic and a lot people
also had questions about this is the
whole tablet game so first question is
what tablet do you use
ahaha so yeah so I use Nexus
yeah I have the the latest Nexus 7 okay
yeah I have a Nexus I'm probably like
the last remaining Nexus 10 loyalists
like I love my Nexus 10 I love the
front-facing speakers on what what sort
of future plans is motorola have for
tablets you know we we wanted to we
wanted to focus on on what is the
largest market today in the market that
that we think where we can offer the
most which is really to start with the
phone the phone is the device the
primary device for everybody usually tap
will tablets a secondary bit device no
one really buys a tablet if they don't
already have a smart if they unless they
already have a smart phone and lots of
people in the world don't have smart
phones so again that's why we went with
moto G so tablets are interesting I
think you know larger form factors in
general are interesting you know I can't
share anything about our product plans
but it's certainly an area that we're
we're exploring it again with we're just
starting to release products if you have
X you have G there's a whole set of
products that are coming so I just say
stay tuned know yeah I thought the Nexus
7 success was really interesting because
of the price point sure
getting people again accessibility to a
really high quality product at such a
low price so interesting to see that the
philosophy with the next with the Moto G
being successful as well um so another
thing is I've read recently that Samsung
was is basically takes up more than half
of or something like that of like the
Android device market share how does how
does anyone compete with that like or do
they compete with that how do you guys
moves and change your strategy well I
you have to look at this market and if
you were go back just eight years
Motorola was the number two player
globally with something like 22 percent
share Motorola shipped 220 million
devices in 2006 that's a huge number of
devices and and things changed but the
iPhone came out blackberry was
successful Nokia was the number one
player at that time yeah so this is a
it's a it's a market where the
technology is changing all the time the
approaches are changing all the time
what's important to consumers changes
all the time so I think it's just a
matter for us of what's let's let's do
what we know we can do best
let's build product that fills needs
that we think are not being met in the
marketplace focusing on what the
consumer wants you know we think that
there's we just keep doing that and good
things will happen okay so speaking of
focusing on what the consumer wants
another popular question in the the
Google Plus events page was just about
just the general philosophy behind the
Moto X when I went to the launch earlier
uh it seemed like the philosophy was um
that people don't really want
necessarily a 1080p display they're
really happy with like a high quality
720p display and the sort of philosophy
of getting the right compromises to make
a device hit that nice price point of
the Moto X and be really a really nice
experience do you think people want like
a just all-around nope no compromises
just high-quality flagship high-end
device like something yeah so our
philosophy with
motox was we wanted to design a device
that was really usable and had a simple
intuitive customer experience and and in
android believe it or not that's often
not the case a lot a lot of Android
devices are not intuitive the software
uh you have conflicting applications you
have to address books you have to music
players right you have you have lots of
software on top of what's become a very
beautiful operating system which is
Android so that was one clear goal that
we had another goal was we wanted a
phone that hit the sweet spot of the
market and was was really something that
that had broad appeal and and we we
thought that having you know the curve
back a very accessible UI the screen
size choices all those choices were made
with the broadest set of consumers in
mind and we also thought that consumers
wanted to be involved in actually
designing their device and having some
choice all right so that's why we went
we built Moto maker but but we also
thought thought that moto maker was the
beginning of a much kind of more
exciting and longer-term story which is
how do we involve consumers in building
their phone and given them or give them
more choice and you know are as much
further out but you can see how those
two things tie together and how as we
introduce new materials into moto maker
we're going to pursue that theme across
our product line going forward so so
that was what we were trying to do with
Moto X nice so do you think in between
Moto X and ara there's going to be more
customizable moto of Motorola phones
with similar oh yeah well what you'll
see is is you'll see more materials and
that's already you know that's already
in process you'll see you'll see
different materials that have different
properties which you know some things
could be pretty cool that we're working
on and and what we'd like to eventually
get to is is functionality in the device
but that's where the line between ara
and what we're doing with Moto maker
might might converge and that might take
some time but that's ok yeah ok um so
what is some some random thing that you
think a Motorola fan would not know
about Motorola some ran an interesting
fact
about or you or motorola in general ah
well here's a random interesting fact
that may or may not be su did you know
that the first transmission from the
moon the the famous words one small step
for man yeah one giant leap for mankind
those were made over a Motorola radio
why and the story is that NASA had a
radio that it already had planned them
for the lunar mission but it wasn't
going to be in the Fadel the the quality
of voice to transmit that to the world
and they realized there's all this
attention we have to be able to transmit
what Neil Armstrong says to the world so
they they called up a bunch of Motorin
motorola engineers two months before the
launch which is not a lot of time and
say hey we need a radio that was going
to have telephone quality sound and that
can reach the moon and they literally
worked 24 hours until the launch to get
that into the into the spacecraft so
that that's that's pretty cool story I
think it also shows that heritage is
still with Motorola it's it's a company
that tries to take big leaps hey let's
build a phone for one-third the cost of
the iPhone but with a bigger screen a
better screen you know latest OS all
that stuff and and and the team responds
really well to those kinds of challenges
definitely so what are the kinds of what
are the kinds of challenges are you guys
focusing on a mobile because I need we
went over like having a very refined
product selection and I'm working on
maintaining them which I'm assuming is a
huge challenge in the first yes and the
challenge of being able to receive a
massive amount of orders with moto maker
and supply all that what other sort of
challenges you guys face so I think you
know one thing that we're all so excited
about is the future of entertainment on
the mobile device if you think about
movies when the projection camera was
invented entertainment totally changed
it went from stage acting to films and
the whole medium came into being and
then television came along and you had
series and all that and and now but with
the phone we're kind of watching the
same stuff that we watched on TV or on
the Internet
even though the phones smaller it can do
a bunch of different things and with
windy day we said okay how do we change
the
and create a storytelling medium that
that responds to the phone and you know
when you move the phone the perspective
changes there's not a single perspective
that the director defines so we worked
with the Pixar a bunch of former Pixar
folks and an Academy award-winning
director to build windy day but that's
just a beginning and you can think of
this as more of a platform imagine if
imagine if artists and animators and
eventually directors could could produce
entertainment with the phone in mind and
and there are going to be five billion
smartphones out there so there's no
doubt that the phone is going to be its
own form of entertainment its own form
of entertainment the medium is going to
change so we think that's really cool
and potentially really big and so we're
going to continue to do things like
windy day and eventually that could
become a platform on its own that could
be really really significant so that's a
big challenge for the team yeah but one
we're excited about nice so yeah I've
heard a lot about people like just
waking up there motox and finding windy
day and just being blown away by it so
people love that so that's really cool
he has a little gift that we wanted to
give ya ya know a lot of people I know
someone who just recently got a moto X
and couldn't stop telling me about it
like playing with it like look at what
I'm doing with this phone right now can
you physically that's awesome um so I
want to shift a little bit to a new form
factor so project ara I don't know if it
if I consider it a new form factor but
it is a totally new technology but stuff
like wearable tech like is definitely a
new form factor and I get with uh you
know RIT I play with galaxy gear so
that's a sort of wearable on your wrist
and Google glass which is I guess closer
to home because you guys are with Google
and that's that's sort of a more popular
thing that people know about so what do
what do you personally think of wearable
tech and I guess what is more ROS
philosophy towards wearable tech yeah so
we're working on a lot of things let me
put it that way
the couple different areas there's
there's clearly going to be something
that changes on your wrist how it works
and what exactly it is is something that
our teams are
working on hard but whatever it is it
has to compete with what works now
so watch is now and they can be very
expensive and like jewelry or they can
be very inexpensive even the inexpensive
watches battery life is you know I never
have to worry about changing the battery
and my my Timex watch you don't really
think about it there they tend to be
indestructible so any any product that
comes along that really wants to change
that human behavior has to think about
those basic problems and what you're
competing against which is usually an
inexpensive watch that works pretty well
for the consumer so that's the challenge
we've given the team we can't have
something that's fragile you can't have
something you have to charge every day
you're gonna have to have some
functionality that's just killer
otherwise why you know why spend the
money on on yet another product so
that's that's when when you come to
watches that's how we're thinking about
I think there's other areas though that
are interesting there's there's in
general imaging in general is changing
radically and how you take pictures and
how you record and one of the killer
apps for Google glasses is of course
taking a picture and taking video right
there's some things there that are
exciting for us and then in ear
technology is also pretty interesting
and Motorola's been the leader in
Bluetooth headsets for a while we can
take that technology and shrink it down
and you can start thinking about really
cool things you can do both both related
to your phone and commanding your phone
or listening to information that might
be supplied by your phone in a way
that's much more subtle so we think
there's some interesting things there as
well yeah yeah I what you said about I
guess just giving more functionality
outside of or just giving us sort of a
unique functionality when you talked
about wristwatches that's like really
important to a lot of people on a lot of
watches so there's the pebble there's
the the Sony SmartWatch those the the
Galaxy gear the challenge is like giving
you a reason to buy that exactly a
reason what's the why is it going to be
so awesome that you have to have that's
the question yeah so that's that's a
huge that's a huge challenge and I think
the the second that someone finds like a
really genuinely useful or unique way to
to utilize a wearable tech and give you
something extra some extra functionality
or something that's going to be really
important so good to hear you guys are
working on that a new motor oil-- has
done that before there was the Moto
active it's more of a sports oriented
watch so we have the tech we certainly
have the skills to do some pretty
interesting right okay um so to wrap up
uh I think I've gone through all of my
like general like most frequently asked
questions and I wait can I ask one yeah
got it okay what do you want in it let's
play forward a year from now what are
the things that you would like to see in
any device that no one is thinking about
today oh that no one is thinking about
well I I'm right now I'm looking at like
other things that everyone is thinking
about like I want a better camera and
like everybody phone I buy I want a
beautiful screen um I think I made a
little rent video earlier this year on
battery technology mmm and how just the
fact that it seems weird that that we if
you go back maybe seven or eight years
you didn't charge your phone every night
you charged it maybe every three or four
nights and they weren't smart phones and
they weren't huge super powerful devices
uh but the the amount of things your
phone can do now has gone up so much and
accordingly our battery life has not so
you get a razor max yeah that's right
relax right now today battery life is
messing with a couple of phones that
have like massive batteries RAZR MAXX is
one of them and I love that it lasts two
days easily on a charge so that's good
um but I want to see more of that I want
to see more people pushing the envelope
in terms of how long a phone can last
and just sort of no worries phone I
guess is what I would want no worries
you don't have to worry about taking a
picture you just take it and you know
it's going to be a good picture you
don't worry about you know charging your
phone everyday you just use it and
whatever you know it's fine
so that's that's I think what a lot of
people look for in terms of
functionality and that's personally what
I am most pumped for is better than a
tree life yeah and another thing is 4k
which I don't even know if it makes any
sense to have anything 4k related in a
mobile device I have a 4k TV behind me
um just
a little burst of 4k products I've seen
in the last like month is pretty
impressive and I know if one phone that
I've used that can shoot 4k video but
anyone who watches my videos knows I'm
I'm like a pixel junkie
I love pixels lots and lots of pixels
though I love the rage of Max's display
I love 1080p displays and phones so just
looking for a way to get more pixels
seeing 4k everywhere is great but it
might not have anything to do with
phones yeah good okay cool
yeah but uh so that's basically it for
the questions if you have anything else
to plug where people can follow I know
you move showed the the what is it the
RL length or was it was aura it's it's
it's D scale calm okay uh backslash aura
okay so that's where people can keep up
with aura what you do well yeah you sign
you can sign up there and then you'll
you'll be uh you'll be given missions or
asked if you want to participate in
missions that the team is is chartering
people on what they're doing is they're
they're soliciting ideas for an actual
projects so it's it's pretty interesting
okay so that's ro you guys if you're
watching this now and you haven't
already registered and you want to do
something cool do that um and of course
you can follow Motorola and Dennis on
Google+ and you can follow me anywhere
you want
Adam kay PhD everywhere ah but that's
about it
I'm thank you for your time I know you
guys super busy with all the things are
doing with Moto X right now and and all
the things are working on so I
appreciate you taking the time to do
this hangout um but I think that's gonna
be it I'm gonna wrap it up thanks again
and I'll talk to everyone or maybe
almost everyone who's watching in the
next one
thanks for kiss take it easy you too bye